le jour était pas à des prises de
décision n'était pas du tout à dire on
va faire si on va faire ça pas du tout
ce qui était important c'est que on
puisse les uns et les autres exprimer
nos inquiétudes notre douleur de ce qui
s'est passé et aussi ce qu'on imagine
pouvoir éventuellement faire donc je
dirais qu'il y a eu une écoute voilà
après ce qu'on a été entendu je ne sais
pas et qu'est-ce qui va se mettre en
place je ne sais pas non plus
[Musique]
alors il y a eu des remarques malgré
tout sur le fait qu'on ait supprimé les
polices de proximité on a aussi évoqué
le plan Borlo qui pour nous a été
échangé déplacé enlever il a été évoqué
également très rapidement le fait que il
va falloir peut-être être un tout petit
peu plus attentif à tout ce qui fait
l'éducation des enfants et l'autorité
parentale également le fait que la
justice
puisse avoir les mains un peu plus
libres par rapport à tout ce qui est je
dirais la condamnation éventuelle bien
sûr des mineurs
[Musique]
dans la pandémie c'est quand même les
mères qui étaient au premier front et là
qui sait qui était sur le trottoir dans
les nuits blanches avec dans les
voitures banalisées c'est nous c'est les
élus donc c'est ça qu'on veut faire
comprendre au président et ce que
j'aurais dû faire comprendre c'est que
quand on a des élus qui ne viennent pas
du terrain qui n'ont pas d'expérience de
terrain comme certains parlementaires
malheureusement et qui ne savent pas ce
que c'est que le quotidien et bien ça
peut pas vraiment bien fonctionner donc
oui merci de nous avoir reçus mais on
existe et heureusement qu'on exit si on
n'existait pas je peux vous dire que la
France est gris beaucoup plus mal encore
beaucoup plus mal
[Musique]